thanks Sarah so I don't want to include
the easy mode of my gaming master since
I still want the official version of the
game to be the standard difficulty but I
do want to include all the latest
changes from master in the easy mode
branch to do this I'll first check out
the easy mode branch so the easy mode
will update whenever I make changes then
I'll run git merge master easy mode now
get alerts me there was a merge conflict
in game J s this means that both
branches master and easy mode changed
the same part of games is just like when
Rachel and Jake both modified the same
line git can't know which changes to
keep so I'll have to resolve the
conflicts to resolve the conflict I need
to open game jeaious and find where the
conflict occurred now get represents
conflicts using these special lines so I
can always find it by searching for a
bunch of less than signs in a row if I
scroll down I can see that these lines
divide the screen into three sections
1 2 3
the top section marked head is my code
the bottom section marked master is the
code that's in master right now and the
middle section is the original version
that both branches modified which get
calls the common ancestor now when I'm
trying to resolve a merge conflict the
first thing I do is try to understand
what changes both branches have made the
difference between the middle section
and the top shows the changes that I
made in the easy mode branch if I've
forgotten what those changes were I can
spend a few minutes comparing and recall
that the difference was changing this 3
to a 2 the difference between the middle
and the bottom shows the changes that
were made in master and it happens that
this particular change was made by Sarah
it's pretty common when I'm resolving
merge conflicts that one set of changes
will be made by me and the other by
someone else so I might need to go talk
to that person but first I always try to
understand what they were doing by
looking at the changes they made here it
looks like Sarah replaced this entire
section of code with a call to a
function called break into fragments now
that probably means that she created
this function and moved this code into
that function which is a pretty common
way to make code more readable by
breaking it up in
- understandable parts now I need to
find this function that she wrote to see
if she just moved the code over or if
she also changed something I could
search for it but in this case it turns
out that it's right up here now it might
look like this function existed in both
versions since it's not inside the
special merge conflict lines but
actually that's just because this change
didn't create a conflict now after I
spent a few minutes comparing this
function to the code that was removed by
Sarah below I could see that she didn't
make any changes to the code other than
to move it now how should I reserve this
merge conflict on the next screen
rewrite the code to what you think the
final version should be make sure to
remove all of these special lines for
example if I wanted to undo my changes I
could just delete my version and the
original version as well as these
special lines to leave only Sarah's code
instead you should create a version of
the code that incorporates both of our
changes